I want to break the myth in this video
that you need to go make a million
dollars that you need money to make
money one two three four five six ten
different ways you can make a million
dollars for little or zero money down
and you can apply this to a thousand
dollars a hundred dollars a hundred
million dollars you can do any of these
things and add or to track the amount of
zeros that you feel comfortable with the
first thing that you can do if you want
to make a million dollars you can sell
something for a million dollars and as
crazy as what I'm saying sounds you
absolutely can sell something for a
million dollars if you go to an
e-commerce store and they're doing a
hundred million dollars a year and you
say hey if I can increase your
conversion across your entire site
rewrite your emails redo your landing
pages and I can get you a five percent
lift can I get one percent of that so
you make them an extra five million a
year and you get one do you think you
can do that yes why are you gonna be
able to do so much not because of you
but because of who they are you make a
million dollars by selling someone else
five to ten million dollars of value and
you're like I don't know how to do that
that's fine but accept that you don't
know how to do that and then say I want
to learn how to do that and then go get
this skill of doing that and then you
can go sell it you can't say that you
don't have the money and that's why you
can't make money the second one is that
you can borrow a million dollars and
then buy something and have someone else
pay it back it's fundamentally what real
estate is you borrow money to buy an
asset you put tenants into the asset
they pay off the money that you never
had that is what real estate is and I'll
tell you a quick story on this so buddy
of mine got into real estate was
flipping houses didn't think there was a
lot of money in it was like oh this
sucks there's so much work and there's
all those 10 you know so he ended up
buying a 14 unit apartment building with
someone else's money he didn't have any
bought the apartment building and then
sold it four months later for 500 000
more and you made 500 Grand in one
transaction and so then he realized that
the more expensive the building he sold
the more money he made then he started
getting into commercial real estate
which is even more expensive he's like
wait a second I can buy something for 10
million and then I can flip it to
somebody for 13 and not even hold on to
it for that long he started flipping 30
or 40 of these a year with just Him and
a couple of va's number three is you
refinance something for more than you
bought it so if you're like but I don't
know if they'll do that they will if
it's priced low enough so if you have to
go talk to a thousand building owners
you will probably get one of them who's
willing to depart for their thing for
significantly less than its worth and a
bank will loan the difference and you
don't have to put any money down out of
pocket let's say you have a hundred
thousand dollar house and you get it
under contract for eighty thousand
dollars from them saying that they're
willing to give you the house for eighty
thousand dollars and then you say cool I
can give you 70 and then you gotta
seller finance me the 10 over the next
five years and they say sure and now all
of a sudden you just got to get the bank
and the bank finance is eighty percent
and now you actually just made the
difference if you wanted to and you can
take that number and you can do it at
100 million dollars you can do it at any
of these levels but that's the concept
does that make sense number four is that
you get a contract for something for
less than it's worth and then you sell
that contract an option is a contract to
say that you will be able to buy
something at a future date at a price
that is agreed upon today that's what an
option is if I agree upon a price to
somebody today then I as the person
who's getting the option is hoping that
it is worth more than that the first
news selling the option is hoping that
it's either worth less than that in the
future or doesn't think it's going to
change significantly it will just get
paid for that tiny option for the
contract itself let's say you've got a
million dollar house now you call a
bunch of houses you're going to be
offering 20 below what the market rate
is that you believe the houses were
eventually you're going to get to
somebody who's like you know what I've
had this house for 30 years I bought it
for ten dollars and now it's worth 800
Grand you know what I'll take the 800
Grand you think it's worth more than 800
and you say thank you I'm going to send
you a DocuSign they sign the DocuSign
that you have an option period to flip
the house you could go to a real estate
investor and say hey I have a house for
nine hundred thousand dollars on sale
right it's worth a million the guy says
okay sure I'll sign for 900. this guy's
gonna put 900 in you're going to pay 800
to this person and then you make the 100
in between and you put no money down the
next one you can do is that you can sell
something that's really expensive and
get a commission sounds really simple
you sell a skyscraper that's a 100
million dollar skyscraper you'll get
three four percent of that deal three or
four million dollars on a single
transaction if you sell a 20 million
residence and you might be like that's
crazy they exist look on Zillow the
realtor gets five-ish percent of the
transaction that's a million dollars
they never owned the asset the next one
is that you can find somebody who has an
audience buy whatever they're about to
launch early and then sell it later now
that one does take some money it's less
but the the value of the thing later
that's how it balloons this is how the
entire nft thing worked is that you have
tremendous demand for a scarce resource
they have the scarce resource and then
it balloons the price because there's so
many people bidding against each other
to get it and so getting in early on
those types of things which is why if
you buy into something pre-ipo it tends
to almost always go up simply by the
fact that there's way more eyeballs that
are competing for most times the next
one is selling units of stuff super
simple but people don't do the math
behind this I don't even like confining
it to a year but you know we do live in
time and so I will explain it that way
if you wanted to make a million dollars
you've got 52 weeks in a year about
twenty thousand dollars a week is what
you got to make 20 times 52 it's
technically a million forty thousand for
the internet trolls how many different
ways can you make 20 grand in a week
well you can sell 20 people a thousand
dollar thing two people a ten thousand
dollar thing one person every four weeks
an eighty thousand dollar thing on a
weekly basis 20 people who have a
thousand dollar lifetime value for
example if you have 100 a month
membership and the person stays for 10
months on average then if you sell 20 of
those every week over time those will
stack up and then you will cap add a
million dollars and the only way to grow
from that new million is either you got
to sell more units or you got to make
the thing that you're selling worth more
that's it the next one is that you can
get people to give you their businesses
for no money down good friend of mine
actually did this and he combined four
different information businesses into
one business and they were all small
businesses they were all doing about a
millionish a year I get Small's relative
but like and so he combined them all to
be a four million dollar Top Line
million and a half bottom line business
for no money out of pocket he literally
said hey I know you don't want to do
this business anymore just give it to me
and I'll pay you the income that you're
going to make for this business for the
next two years and they said sure and so
you combined all those businesses
together and then overnight he owned an
asset that was doing a million and a
half a year in profit and four million
in Top Line and it cost him nothing to
do it he owns the asset now and so if he
turned around and went to say hey I'm
gonna go sell this he could probably
sell the thing for five million dollars
put together it might cost him two
million bucks and he makes the three he
made more than a million dollars with no
money out of pocket understand that the
people who are making money don't
constrain themselves by time they're not
thinking how do I make X dollars per
hour x dollars per year they're thinking
how do I provide the most value to
somebody so they'll give me a percentage
of the value I provide here's another
one is that you can go find stuff that
you really like and go promote that so
you don't have to go find and make your
own products you go find products that
you really like from other companies and
just become Affiliates of those products
and the nice thing is that I just
recommend you be honest be like hey I
tried 100 [ __ ] different soaps this
is my favorite one and here's why people
don't want to go through the time and
the money of figuring out which soap is
the best for your audience and if you
make the rack after you do that they're
like oh well shoot he just saved me time
and so then I'll go buy from him through
his link or whatever and so you can
affiliate other people's products and
make money in that way without any money
out of pocket and then finally Arbitrage
in general which is a fancy word but it
just means that you sell the same thing
between two different markets because
they're priced differently if Bitcoin is
nineteen thousand dollars in Japan on
the Japanese Market is 19 100 in the US
market you buy the nineteen thousand
dollar Bitcoin over in Japan and you
sell it in the American market for 1901
and you make a hundred bucks that's all
Arbitrage is and it happens with
physical products it happens with
lending money between two parties if you
can get money for one percent and you
can sell the money for six percent you
make five is the difference all of these
are different versions of Arbitrage
which is just same thing two markets two
different prices you make the difference
and so if you're looking for ways to
make money look for Arbitrage
opportunities because that's where you
can make tremendous income